Hi, everyone.
In this lesson, we're going to go and take a look again
at the subsurface materials and all the details
that we can create from a simplistic ICE type of effect
to one that's a little bit more complex.
So let's get started.
We saw in the last lesson how
we can create a Fernal Index node inside of our opacity
as well as our subsurface inputs.
And we actually could get some pretty good effects.
Now, this doesn't actually have to be really complex.
It can be pretty simple, which
I'm going to show you in just a second.
But you can also add a bit of complexity
with a World Alignment Texture node,
which allows us to be able to blend things
such as the subsurface textures,
as well as even the normals,
which actually work really well,
which I do show you in another class.
But in this particular case,
let's go and take a look at each one of these
and how we can create some really great things.
Now, you also could use a more complex Fernal Index
if you wanted to.
And it gives you a breakdown here
of exactly what each one of those inputs do.
Do you need it?
Not necessarily.
Sometimes less is more.
But you do have the option of getting a cheap contrast,
dark and light, if you want, or dark and bright.
But that's really up to you,
as well as you can invert the effect if you needed to
as adjusting things also with a camera vector
or a normal vector, which is kind of nice.
But we're not going to get into this particular one.
We do talk a bit about this in previous classes.
But for the most part,
I'm going to show you exactly what we can do,
keeping things even low key or even a bit more complex.
You can go in any direction when it comes to Unreal.
And your possibilities are endless on what you can create.
You can see several versions I have here
using that same complex version I made for Jade,
allowing me to control my subsurface opacity,
as well as my subsurface look and feel.
You can see some really great effects here.
So let's go ahead and jump into Unreal
and take a look at some things.
With this particular ice,
you'll see that it looks pretty great
and actually works really well.
As I move my light around,
you can see the effect of the edge here
being affected with our light.
And it seems to be working really well.
And it's using a bit of that Fresnel index information
to get what we need.
Let's actually click on this up close
and take a look at some things.
We're going to go and click on that new ice.
And you'll notice this is really simple.
Again, we are using the subsurface material shading model.
And in here,
we simply just have a normal punched in and opacity.
So you'll notice you don't necessarily have to have
a Fresnel index for your opacity,
but it can help with that bending effect of the light
and that making things look, you know,
either glass or ice-like, it's up to you.
Here, I just have a simple opacity control,
but that can change.
Again, you can imitate what I did with the jade
and that effect to be able to actually push things
in the direction that you need.
And you'll see a simple Fresnel index.
Now, again, we have several different Fresnel indexes
like we talked about before that we can use.
Now you'll notice there's a Fresnel function.
That's the one that I pointed out
just a minute ago in the slides.
If I click on this,
you can see this one has a lot more you can add to it.
If I wanted to,
I could use this also as an output
for my subsurface profile,
as well as punching it into my opacity.
We can use a normal vector
and here we can use a color information that we need
if we wanted to.
And you'll see here, there's a V3 for a camera vector.
We can use RGB information for position if we wanted to.
And I'll show you what I mean.
So if I hit the three key here,
I can punch this in right into our camera
vector information.
And if I wanted to,
I could pull that right into my sub surface color.
Now you'll notice it's whited it out
because it's using RGB information
to be able to gather things like an XYZ.
It kind of translates that way.
But if I go in here and change my color information,
you'll actually see some things change within your scene.
We'll choose something that may give us a bit more
of a better output,
but you'll notice it's very slight.
You'll also see the light kind of change
if we get a good angle there.
As I run through this,
we saw it just a second ago.
You'll see the highlights kind of change,
but it's really up to you how you want to do it.
So let's actually hit, let's do yellow for now.
You'll see an update.
So we can choose, ooh, kind of cool deep
on the other side there, look at that color.
So we can choose whatever we want, whatever color.
And we do need a few more things to play with those.
We do that up, see that update there?
Pretty cool.
So, and what I mean by that is we can actually go in here
and say, hey, I want a normal vector.
What is that going to be?
And I can hit the three key again
and pull in a normal vector
and also change those values of what I want.
We'll go more of a reddish pink color and hit okay.
And you could see, you can get an infinite combo.
And again, it's using that RGB information
to be able to produce different looks and feels.
It's really up to you how you want to do it.
Cool.
And you can get like even a deep rich tone to your ice
if you wanted to.
So you could see that where this would play
and work out pretty well.
And we do talk a bit about this in other classes
but I just wanted to show you briefly
how you can go from simple to complex
by simply just adding a few more values.
And again, we have some power control overall
which could be a scaler as well as cheap contrast
and so forth if we wanted to go in here
and a cheap contrast dark.
And you can simply just go in here
and say promote to a parameter.
And you're going to get that node
that fits really well for cheap contrast.
And you can get the idea of what you can do.
It's pretty great.
Cool.
And those are static bullions
if you're unfamiliar with the SP.
I probably should mention that.
All right.
So let's go ahead and take a look
at the other more complex ice over to the side here.
Now he's just slightly complex
in the fact that we actually can use this in such a way
and I just duplicated a piece of ice here.
I could shove it into another object
and the subsurface alignment is working really well.
Now there is no alignment node world aligned texture node
inside of the normal.
So you're going to see a harsh line that will show up
but just the same as we use it for the subsurface
we can actually use it for our normals
so that they blend a bit better.
And we go over that in another class
called world composition.
But in here, let's go and take a look
at how this ice is broken up.
Let me go to pull this over.
So in this particular environment
we see that we're using a world aligned texture
and we're stacking them in such a way.
We have an add, multiply, and then an add
putting them in our scene and controlling the texture size.
And we're putting that right in combo
with a multiply, a subsurface color, a subsurface scale.
And we're bringing that right
into the subsurface color here.
And that allows us to control the look
and feel a bit more for that subsurface variety
if we needed it.
And if we instance these
we can make each one look a little bit different
than the other.
Now you do need to expose parameters when you do this.
So what that means is you want to convert
to a parameter here, as well as any other items
such as your scalers.
Like you might want to convert this one too
and say, hey, this is going to control
overall alignment amount.
And this one here, subsurface scale
which is already promoted.
And then this one here could be just color amount here
and you can convert that to a parameter.
And when you create an instance
you'll be able to have access to those
and edit those accordingly.
Pretty great to be able to have this ability
to be able to do this
and to be able to control your subsurface
and have all these things at your fingertips.
So keep those things in mind.
So that's it with this video.
In the next video, we're going to go ahead
and take a look at the parallax occlusion shader
and what that means as well as the bump offset
and compare them from a more complex
which would be parallax to a more simple bump offset
and which one would be better
and the ins and outs caveats for each.
Thanks again.